l'avenir du bois de l'étang un dossier
sur la table de la municipalité depuis
plusieurs années au coeur d'un débat
entre les habitants avec cette question
une rénovation des bâtiments avec ou
sans destruction un sujet abordé par le
président du département des yvelines
pierre bédier lors de son déplacement
dans le quartier le département était
favorable aux destructions comme la
région comme l état parce que nous
savons par expérience lorsqu'il ya des
quartiers enclavés
on comprend bien l'inquiétude des gens
sur les démolitions mais le
désenclavement est nécessaire pour que
le quartier puissent respirer pour qu'on
puisse mieux vivre nous savons par
expérience que s'il n'y a pas ces
démolitions le quartier va se dégrader
aujourd'hui le maire a un projet en tête
la destruction de trois bâtiments sur 10
212 foyers seraient donc concernées par
la charte intercommunale de relogement
ce plan devrait être déposé à l'agencé
nationale de rénovation urbaine courant
mai avec à la clé près de 60 millions
d'euros de financement une zone
commerciale dynamiser un quartier plus
accessible une entrée de ville digne de
ce nom une grande coulée verte pour
renforcer le côté nature des pistes vélo
voilà toutes les ambitions sont
traduites dans ce plan masse plusieurs
habitants sont en désaccord avec ce
projet opposés à la destruction il
préfère une rénovation des bâtiments
existants
ils sont soutenus par le collectif des
locataires qui propose un projet
alternatif
on n'a pas concertés sur ce projet et
notre content aujourd'hui c'est sur la
participation citoyenne des as du temps
sur ce projet nous on a eu un architecte
nous a fait déjà un projet sont démolis
seront encore plus techniques d immonde
et là on s'attaque sur tous les espaces
extérieurs et donc on essaie d'améliorer
les dysfonctionnements mais sens des
mots ni font les concertations vont se
poursuivre du côté de la mairie et du
collectif des locataires avec la volonté
de servir au mieux l'intérêt des
habitants de ce quartier